yeah a level curve is a general concept
referring to any any the taking a two
dimensional function sorry a two
variable function ie a three dimensional
surface setting the height of that
function equal to some constant and
asking for all combinations of the input
variables that give you that height that
would be a level curve I soak want is
specifically terminology used for
production functions in economics like
isotherm also level curve is
specifically for temperature ok ok ok
good so that's multivariate functions
how do we how do we optimize
multivariate functions well how did we
optimize the univariate functions
anybody remember well you're so you have
to find the derivative set that equal to
zero and then you have to solve that
equation it may involve looking for two
roots if it happens to be a quadratic
function it may involve looking for more
roots if it's a higher order function
probably not in most of the toy examples
we will do in class but but in
real-world applications you generally
will have many more roots but you won't
have to do them by hand you'll be able
to use matlab or you know something like
that or an equation solver ok so when we
have multivariate functions the process
is exactly the same we're going to be
looking for a combination of input
variables such that the slope of the
function is equal to zero
but now because we have multiple
variables the derivative is just a
slightly more complicated beast than it
was before in the case of univariate
function the derivative was just the
slope of that function or a or a
function that gives you the slope for
different values of x ok now what's the
analog of the derivative in the case of
multivariate function it's called a
partial derivative ok now the partial
derivative you can think of that's why I
drew the cross section here the partial
derivative is simply the slope off an
analog function holding a bunch of input
variables constant ok so if you're
looking for the partial derivative with
respect to labor in that yield function
i talked about you hold fertilizer input
constant you'll be able to draw a sorry
actually i switch the variables on you
this is holding holding labor constant
so if I whole labor constant I can draw
a cross section for how yield changes as
I change Z this cross section function
obviously has an ordinary derivative
this is just a function of one variable
Z so you could take you could take let's
call F Y as a function of Z given that B
is equal to 2 you could take F Prime
with respect to Z to be the slope of
this function
and this f prime is just the what we
call the partial derivative with respect
to Z okay that is how the slope of the
function what is the slope of the
function as you change Z while holding
constant B again you will have the
analog definition if you were looking
for the partial derivative with respect
to be okay so and so here's the the
formal definition the partial derivative
of F X Y with respect to X it's written
this way sort of a squiggly D is the
derivative of the function where Y is
treated as a constant iey is given at
some constant value and f is considered
as if it were a function of X alone okay
so that's exactly what this is okay hold
all other variables constant and change
just the one variable with respect to
which you're taking the partial
derivative and this logic applies if the
function is a function of more than two
variables the partial derivative by
definition is always with respect to a
single variable holding all others
constant okay okay so what's the
interpretation of the partial derivative
well it is simply the rate of change of
the function with respect to X for all
other variables held constant for all
other input variables held constant
right or keeping all other input
variables constant what is the what's
the change in the output variable for a
small change in X
when X is the variable with respect to
which you are taking the partial
derivative okay so how do you do partial
differentiation well the mechanics are
very simple since we assume that all
other by definition the partial
derivative assumes that all other
variables are kept constant you can
treat all other variables as a constant
and as such they're derivative would be
zero so take for example this function
5x cubed Y squared and you want to find
the partial derivative with respect to X
you could think of this function as a
function simply of X with this Y squared
as part of the constant okay so here
I've written it as if 5y squared is some
constant times X cubed okay well if you
had some constant times X cubed and you
had to take and it was just a univariate
function of X then what would be its
derivative 333 x squared times the
constant okay so that's what you have 3x
squared times the constant so don't
forget the constant right okay similarly
here you have a slightly more
complicated function this is a function
of x and y inside the brackets to the
power 8 okay so you could simply think
of this is 4x that's the function of X
plus 3y minus 5 that's some constant
raised to the power 8 okay so it's as if
we f is really 4x plus some constant
raised to the power 8 okay this is f of
X so f prime of X here would be what 8
ok something in there to the power 7
okay so that's going to be 4x plus C am
I done x 4 right plus the inside
derivative so i could just multiply here
by four okay and you would be you would
be just fine so that's four times 8 is
32 okay and that's what you have here
except that you know this C is really 3y
minus five okay
yeah so this see I just defined this
constant on the fly meaning when I look
at this expression this is a function of
x and y however i'm looking for the
partial derivative with respect only 2 X
in other words i'm taking a cross
section of that function holding Y
constant since I'm holding Y constant I
can pretend this is really a constant
and this I know is a constant so on the
fly i defined see to be this constant it
just made it simpler so that when i took
the derivative it was easier ok
everybody good ok so let's look at that
heat loss problem again we've got the
heat loss function that we worked out
before as a function of x y&z so let's
say where we have to calculate and
interpret the partial derivative with
respect to X that was the length of the
building if the current dimensions of
the building are 10 7 and five length 10
with seven and height five well what's
what's the partial of this with respect
to X what's the partial with respect to
X of this first term 11 y what about
this one what's the partial with respect
to X of the second term zero right this
is we would treat y and z is constant
and the last one would be 15 z ok so
this is 11 y plus 15
head and you could evaluate that at the
value 10 75 it's only a function y and z
so we only use the seven and five gives
you the number 152 well what's the
interpretation of 152 I have the answer
up there but maybe somebody can read it
to us but if X if the length of the
building is increased by one unit right
so if I go from a length of 10 meters oh
I guess this was in feet right 10 feet
to 11 feet then the rate of heat loss
for the building as a whole would
increase by 152 units yes absolutely
partial derivative could be negative in
this case it wouldn't be because heat
loss is going to be increasing as you
increase the dimensions of the building
but there's no for example in the case
of the fertilizer and labor if you
already had passed the optimal level of
Labor and fertilizer and you added more
labor you would have a negative partial
derivative okay okay but now suppose
that we want to find the dimensions of
the building that minimises heat loss
okay as with univariate optimization
we're going to look for critical points
of the multivariate function and those
critical critical points will be
combinations of the input variables such
that the partial derivatives are equal
to zero okay now there are two look for
a minimum or a maximum
there is a first order condition and a
second order condition when we optimized
the univariate functions I didn't tell
you what the second order condition was
because I built it into my description I
told you that if you have a concave
function and you look for a zero of the
ordinary derivative then you are at a
maximum if you have a convex function
and you look for a zero of the ordinary
derivative then you're at a minimum okay
the first order condition is a necessary
but not sufficient condition for
attaining a minimum or maximum okay that
first order condition is that the
derivative is equal to zero if you want
a sufficient condition as well as a
necessary condition then you have to
look at the second order condition in
the univariate case we didn't bother
with that because we simply said that
you'll either be looking at convex
functions or concave functions and if
you're dealing with a concave function
you're going to have a maximum and if
you're dealing with a convex function
you're going to have a minimum okay and
you can remember that by remembering the
shapes of those graphs that I put up
right at the beginning of this session
with multivariate functions you
typically need to think about
second-order conditions more carefully
because there are many more possible
scenarios it's not so much that the
function is concave or convex because
you're in three dimensions now it could
be concave if you take a section along
one axis but convex if you take a
section along the other it could be
concave in both
ways and so on right and if you have
three if you have three input variables
then you're in even more with even many
more probabilities many more
combinations so you would need to look
at the second order condition okay so
we'll talk about the second order
condition in a second the first order
condition is always that the partial
derivatives of both with respect to X
and with respect to Y are equal to 0 and
of course if this were a function of
three variables then all three partials
will have to be equal to 0 and so on
okay for the energy energy loss the heat
loss function we have a function of
three variables if we're looking for a
minimum of this function then we would
have to set all three partials equal to
zero okay now here suppose that we want
to design the rectangular building with
a specific volume of course if you're
building is very small then its heat
loss will be much less than a large
building the key here is to have minimal
heat loss for a particular size so let's
suppose that we set the volume equal to
this I've chosen this number so that its
root is an integer so we don't have to
you know so we can do things nicely okay
we must we have to minimize the heat
loss function such that the volume which
is of course x y times X times y times Z
is is that number okay OST means such
that such that you'll see this a lot
okay good question
okay so we have to minimize that
function well actually this simplifies
things a little bit because we have a
constraint on the potential combinations
of XY and Z and that's going to allow us
to eliminate one of the variables so
instead of a three dimensional problem
we'll have a two dimensional problem
okay so X Y Z has to be this so suppose
that we just call the constant V this
number so that's going to just reduce
the ugliness of the algebra we can
express Z in terms of x and y and v okay
so that's just dividing v by x times y
okay and then we can substitute for z in
the original heat loss equation so it's
going to be 11 x y plus 14y substituting
for z here plus 15x substituting for z
here and i get this equation right okay
okay so to minimize this function we're
going to compute partial derivatives
with respect to x and y equate them to 0
and find the values of X&Y which satisfy
those two equations okay so this is my
heat loss function as a function of x y
and v but v is just a constant so there
are no partial derivatives for that okay
so you you know how to take this partial
derivative with respect to X that's just
11 y and here with respect to X is 14 v
over x squared
okay everybody know how to do that right
and then do the same thing with respect
to Y that's going to be 11 x there's no
y in that term so that's 0 and here
there's a why so it's 15 V over Y
squared okay by the way this is a notice
this minus sign here okay everybody
understand why there's a minus sign here
tell me if you do not understand yes
okay so so that's that right so we had
14 v / x is really 14 v x to the minus 1
okay so when i take this derivative i
take the power and put it in front make
it a coefficient and reduce the exponent
by one so i'll get minus 1 x 14 v x
minus 14 v over x squared okay so we
worked out the partial derivatives we
set them equal to 0 now we've got two
equations in terms of x y and v we know
what v is that's just a constant so we
can solve you know we have these two
equations why is expressed in terms of V
and X so you could just substitute for Y
in here and if you do that and a bit of
algebra you get X or X cubed in terms of
V which we know what that is and V this
number was chosen so that X turns out to
be an integer okay so you you know that
X would be 56 and then once you know
what X is you can work out y and z okay
so the building which minimises heat
loss and has volume equal to that has to
be 56 feet by 60 feet by 44 feet okay so
given so that shape is of course a
function of the particular geography of
that building right and so would change
for a different geography let's talk
briefly about that second order
condition because we are dealing with
now a three-dimensional surface here is
what we call a saddle point this is a
place where a long one section if I
would cut a section this way the
function the cross-sectional function
would look concave
and if I were to cut a section this way
the cross sectional function would look
convex so at this red point here my
partial derivative with respect to this
axis would be zero and the partial
derivative with respect to this axis
would be 0 2 but I'm neither at a
maximum or minimum of that function if I
go a little bit this way I could go
higher if I go a little bit this way I
could go lower okay so I am at a
critical point of the function it's a
saddle point ok so to avoid these kinds
of avoid finding points like this when
we simply set the partials equal to zero
you need to look at the second-order
conditions and most problems that i
would give you would would not involve
that but i do want you to understand
that conceptually and I've given you
what how to work out the second-order
conditions here okay so you could yes
well I'll tell ya I'll tell you in a
second what the word what it has to
satisfy right so if you and this is just
for two variables there are analogs for
larger with larger numbers of variables
so for a function of two variables f as
a function of x and y if the partials
are equal to zero at the point X star Y
star you can define this quantity this
is the this is a function of the Cross
partials this is the second derivative
with respect to x times the second
derivative with respect to Y minus the
cross partial so this is you take a
derivative of the function with respect
to X
and then you take a derivative of that
derivative with respect to Y so it's
called the second-order cross partial
yeah you take so let's say that you you
have a function of x and y you take a
derivative with respect to X ok let's
just call that gee that's also a
function of x and y and then you take a
derivative of G with respect to Y ok
that's what I've call what I put up
there as
okay if you think of a hill and you're
trying to work out how high you would go
if you move in a certain direction
doesn't matter whether you go east and
then north or west north and then east
okay